[Music]
thank you
this is cited in Queens closing in now
cover the door
the Beast could be anywhere
this whole lizard hunt ends now
to hunt I'll give him one he'll never
forget
he's gonna wish he never came to New
York
triangulating positions
Target located at Harlem Fish Market all
teams converge lizards across the river
I'm not gonna make it in time
[Music]
miles the hunters tracked Connors to the
Harlem fish market
wizard
I'm on it sounds like Craven's checking
off his we don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market must be Sushi night you still got
the hunter drone you hijacked and really
tough hiding it for my mom but yeah I'll
boot up and see you there
they got here fast
[Music]
can't let him find Connors or he's done
for it
[Music]
spread out
find them isn't don't engage alone
[Music]
it's fish it's been feeding
I never saw it coming
[Music]
foreign
ers
garage my lead to him
Connor's tore through this place
is out of control
[Music]
where am I now
how'd you find me some of the fish
drones picking up lizards Trail
he's still eating we can catch him off
guard
Yankee get behind me
it's just his skin
doesn't that mean he's getting bigger
hungry or two
hey man any threats the building's
swarming with Hunters any sign of
Connors uh yeah Yankees tracking him hey
Mr Parker
Mr
Spiderman I mean
but the date is incomplete
that wasn't me me neither
I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
go go make him alive
can't lose Connors Harry's dying and
he's the only one who can help we won't
you take the Drone I got the jet skis
thank you
if I borrow this
is really really exciting keep it tight
man watch out for those drones don't
worry they think I'm a friendly
just take him out
East River is not a river but in fact
the saltwater tidal flat Spiderman is
fighting on right now
everybody get out
help the tour boat right I've got the
metal murder bird
I warned you about going after Connors
now this is on you
boys and clouds that all you got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how are you looking
this gunship won't quit I'm right behind
you we'll take it down together no time
I got you time to go boom boys no no no
Spider-Man it's good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
come on go with the cameras
[Music]
it's right behind you I know I know whoa
ski faster fly faster
I do not want to be lizard food
okay
hold on
look out
everyone take cover
what are you guys doing trying to take
out that gunship can't get close enough
but I can't I'm one of them remember bro
that's it hey alley-oop on three hi
ah
two
three Ally
foreign
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
it's mine
sure
it's got big teeth
so do I
why um he's not normally like that right
no
he's never like that